my caramelized cranberry apple sauce is
another recipe I always cook a day in
advance it packs a wonderful punch that
really lifts the subtle flavor of the
turkey it's simple to make and with its
deep red vibrant color looks fantastic
on the plate the secret behind any good
Christmas is in the organization and the
preparation anything can get done in
advance do it apple and cranberry sauce
is a prime example first things first
we're gonna make a really nice caramel
sugar in at 150 grams of caster sugar to
a pan
followed by a couple of star anise that
helps to really give
a nice sort of aniseed flavor to The
Cranberries next lightly crushed four
cardamom pods this has a lovely warm
Spicy Sweet flavor
then wait for the sugar to melt and form
a caramel really important to have the
confidence now to color that caramel so
it gets really nice and dark before
putting the Cranberries in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow smell of that caramel is amazing now
cranberries in
crumb is a very tart and acidic but
balanced with the sweetness of the
caramel and apples they give the sauce a
lovely dry sharp note to tell if they're
fresh drop them on a hard surface the
higher they bounce the fresher they are
the secret now is for the caramel to
blister the cranberries and really start
to break that down
smells fantastic next core peel and
thinly sliced two apples and once the
sauce is finished it really just helps
to sort of wake up
flavor of the turkey Now The Cranberries
are starting to break down Apple in
smells fantastic
salt and pepper
really important really helps to balance
that tartness against the acidity of the
Apple salt and pepper really brings it
back
the smell is fantastic it's a sort of
sweet sour spicy nice
now from there
delays the pan with a touch of port
around the side
deglazing dissolves all the lovely
sticky caramelized bits of food that are
stuck to the pan and incorporates them
into the sauce
next add the zest of an orange
[Music]
and for another layer of fragrance
sweetness squeezing the juice
lovely then cook on a low heat for five
to ten minutes to thicken but remember
the salt will become even thicker once
it's cooled down now that
is the right texture I don't want a
runny sauce I want something really nice
and thick delicious packed full of
flavor
perfect
if you really want to get ahead this
sauce can be made three or four days in
advance and kept in the fridge which
allows the flavors to develop even more
smoked salmon scrambled egg and
croissant it's Rich some just an
incredibly easy to do first the
croissants slice them into rounds and
season them lightly with salt and pepper
the secret behind a really good
breakfast
is in the timing on the quesles on first
smoke salmon on top and then the
scrambled egg put the croissants in a
dry pan and toast you don't need oil
because the castles have a lot of butter
in them
this is a great way to transform day old
croissants giving them a delicious new
life and just start to see them toasted
almost listening
in the pan and that's the butter
inside that smell is amazing it almost
smells like a sort of caramelized waffle
absolutely delicious toast them all
around both sides
and then out next
just get the smoked salmon and sort of
twist it and let it fall
over the castle
let it sit
naturally on top of the toasted
croissant
scrambled eggs
eggs into the pan
never whip up the eggs beforehand
you break down the egg too much what I
want is a really nice rich creamy
scrambled egg eggs in no seasoning at
this stage a nice generous knob of
butter
now
from there
onto the Heat and all we're going to do
now is Stir
and stir and stir
foreign
texture to the eggs it looks rich
delicious Sumptuous luxurious
to be very careful making scrambled egg
all of a sudden it looks runny and
within 30 seconds it's cooked working it
all the time
right after stirring I plastic scraper
in there take the pan off the heat
and just work around the pan cleaning up
all that scrambled egg that's sticking
to the bottom and now look we're getting
that really nice sort of creamy
beautiful texture a little touch of
butter in there now
I'm going to start with the seasoning
30 seconds from the end salt pepper
back on
to the stove and a tablespoon of cream
the cream actually stops the scrambled
egg from overcooking cream in
and then fold that in there now keep
that off the heat
but look at it look at that color
peaceful
and then finally some fresh chives
there's a Ramsey classic smoked salmon
toasted croissant and a delicious
scrambled egg
[Music]
we're gonna make an amazing butter
and this
is sort of the start of the the most
important part keeping that bird
incredibly moist soft butter
a touch of salt and pepper
[Music]
it'll touch up olive oil in there that
stops the butter from burning
next add the zest of two lemons and
their juice this gives the flavor butter
a wonderful Citrus thing
[Music]
three cloves of garlic
turkey is a very delicate dainty meat
and that's why I want the garlic pureed
so it sort of disintegrates and flavors
a turkey gently without becoming too
overpowering then add a generous handful
of chopped parsley
wow that smells incredibly light give
that a good mix
turkey's a very very very lean bird and
it dries out so so important to make
sure that we help it to cook perfectly
butter done now prepare the turkey we'll
season the bird inside the cavity
[Music]
salt and pepper next half two onions and
pop them in as they roast they steam
inside the bird giving it a lovely
sweetness
put in the lemon and a couple of bay
leaves for their Bittersweet spicy
flavor
we're sort of lining the inside of the
turkey with these fantastic sort of
flavors you can see the bird is upright
and it's looking sort of like it's
standing to attention now it's time to
add the flavored butter just very very
carefully open up the skin go through
over the back of the breast and keep the
skin intact
the idea is to gently loosen the skin
with your fingers so the butter can be
stuffed underneath it now once you've
loosened all the skin off the top of the
thighs turn the bird around
and just go through here again hand up
and just release a little bit but don't
completely break it because I don't want
all that butter to run out
right from there
now take your butter
put it into a ball
smells amazing
lemony citrusy and just sort of flatten
it
stick that in there
underneath
one side now once you've got it in there
pull back the skin and just
use that
to sort of slide all the way down
what we want to do now is line the top
of the breast with all that butter there
that butter is going to keep the turkey
breast really seriously moist turn the
bird around
and finish covering the breasts with the
butter
turkey's originally came from North
America and their best young and plump
my favorite breed for Christmas is
either Norfolk black or Norfolk bronze
both of which have a wonderful gamey
taste
take the rest of the butter and
carefully massage over the breasts legs
and wings
can do all this the night before and
simply cover the turkey with tinfoil and
keep it in the fridge ready to be cooked
on Christmas Day
into the tray
[Music]
and it will touch of olive oil now olive
oil on top again that protects it gets
that skin really nice and crispy and it
stops the butter from burning now in the
oven at 220 for 10 minutes get really
nice and brown quickly in she goes
beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that smells fantastic after 10 minutes
take the turkey out of the oven and
baste then cover the breasts with smoked
streaky bacon what I want to do
is add a little bit more flavor I'm
already starting to think about my gravy
so the bacon protects it stops it from
drying out
but it's going to start
to really give
my gravy a wonderful base
turn down the oven to 180 degrees
this five kilogram bird will feed eight
people comfortably it needs roasting for
two and a half hours or half an hour per
kilo basting every so often
back in and now
she's on the way look at that beautiful
as pretty as the Christmas tree that
smells fantastic wow look at that
beautiful that
is 90 of your work done there to test
the turkey is cooked stick a knife into
the bottom of the thigh and if the
juices run clear it's done the secret
now is to let the turkey rest uncovered
for two and a half hours as the meat
relaxes it reabsorbs its juices making
it succulent and tender plus it'll be
easier to carve it might seem like a
long time to let it rest but remember
the turkey doesn't need to be piping hot
because I'm serving it with hot gravy
that looks like a million dollars let
that rest because the flavor will be 10
times more exciting once it's rested
the key to pulling all the different
elements of your Christmas dinner
together on the plate is the gravy my
recipe for turkey gravy made with cider
and walnuts has a wonderful Appley nutty
flavor which beautifully complements the
turkey meat and fruity pork stuffing as
that turkey is resting
I want to make the most amazing gravy
and when I say amazing I really do mean
amazing
drain the excess fat from The Roasting
tray and put it back on the heat then
remove the bacon from the top of the
turkey and the roasted onions from the
cavity look at them
my God they smell amazing finally take
out the roasted lemon
first of all cut up the bacon
lovely
bacon into the tray
there are crispy that is that's the
start
of our gravy the onion look at it
beautiful it doesn't get any better than
that chop that up
onion and bacon in
that
smells
incredible
when I first got the chance to cook
Christmas lunch for the chefs in Paris
they taught me one crucial thing
I was only 21 at the time but they made
me rest the turkey as long as I cooked
it so I cooked it for three hours and I
rested it for three hours what a
difference
incredible
next chop up the roasted lemon and add
to the tray put in a couple of sprigs of
rosemary to give it a lovely aromatic
punch and Fry then add three chopped
tomatoes which helps to thicken the
gravy and give it a lovely fresh taste
it's time to really get the turkey
flavor into the gravy snap off the wing
take off all your little trimmings some
of these little bits here
add that into your gravy these are the
bits we never use
everyone throws them away
off there that little baby there
take him off
I want that
bang flavor delicious try that off
the smell is incredible
next pour in the dry cider this adds a
lovely subtle Apple flavor that really
lifts the taste of the turkey meat as
The Cider starts to reduce pour in the
delicious resting juices from the
roasted turkey wow there you go the most
amazing flavor
foreign
has reduced by half crush the vegetables
and the turkey pieces with a Masher to
extract the maximum amount of flavor
and basically what's happening now is
that we're giving the gravy a little bit
of body
pour in the chicken stock and reduce
again then
now a little taste
[Music]
wow let me just close your eyes and wow
it oozes flavor and turkey now sieve it
back of the ladle to push it through the
sieve extracting every last drop of
flavor
pop in a sprig of rosemary and leave to
infuse ready for the finishing touch
simply add crushed walnuts to the bottom
of the gravy boat and ladle in the hot
gravy